und mein gott ich habe gerade eine
richtige erleuchtung dann muss ich mir
ja immer mitbringt wie das noch kennt
das muss ich aber dringend leute und
bevor es weitergeht die einen anderen
wissen schon abonniert auf jeden fall
den kanal wir sind eine million ist
wenig mal viele leute für sich mehr
darüber freuen
einfach kurz drauf klicken auf
abonnieren und jetzt gehts weiter alters
gedacht und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video ja halt ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut
ja auch ich weiß also eigentlich sind
wir nicht wir dran liegen wir genau in
einer zeit aber ich habe ja jetzt im
november auch schon 45 adventskalender
unboxing gemacht wo ich halt einfach ein
adventskalender ausgepackt hat und eine
haben wir vergessen ich weiß die meisten
von euch haben wir es wahrscheinlich
schon adventskalender trotzdem ist das
glaube ich ganz cool da ist auch noch
rein zu schauen weil es ist ein ganz
besonderer kalender und der ist auch für
mich sah ich mal etwas neues und ich bin
sehr gespannt was da drin ist ich kann
ich mal so viel verraten es geht um
geschichte wir tauchen ab in das
zwanzigste jahrhundert mit 54 wo ist
eigentlich das messer gefunden ok ja
wirklich bin sehr sehr traurig das ist
der letzte adventskalender öffnen werde
eventuell nicht noch den von coca cola
zugeschickt das recht nahe
ich habe euch die kalender wie immer
natürlich in der video beschreibung
verlinkt falls es denn überhaupt noch
gibt aber ich gehe davon aus also wenn
jemand von euch noch einen neuen verein
sucht texas gerne ab ich muss sagen er
ist halt irgendwie ziemlich leicht also
der pocken kalender einen er war das ist
ja wirklich so kommen sollte so das
passt auf wir machen es wie immer
und da sieht man auch schon dass das ein
historisches ding ist wir haben hier
viele historische ereignisse wir haben
hier praktisch alles sachen die nach
vergangenheit liegen wäre mir kleinen
juli also mal kurz so zusammengefasst es
ist ein ddr adventskalender mit soweit
ich weiss produkten aus wer hätte es
gedacht der ddr
ich glaube aber essen also süßigkeit und
so aus der ddr hoffe ich mache weil dann
wirds echt interessant weißt du was ich
mir heutzutage für die frage stellt ob
überhaupt noch die ganzen zehnjährigen
wissen was die ddr war weil manchmal
muss ich mir da wirklich im kopf fassen
wenn ich das allgemeinwissen von manchen
oder die kennen die vor die brennweiten
halten aufforderten wir kennen sie aber
den erkennen sind nicht er ist ja so
fühlt euch jetzt nicht angegriffen also
ich würde sagen wir machen wie rauf und
mal gucken was drin ist schildert jetzt
mache ich das so auch schon überall ist
so so so ein text drin oder so sein buch
reden kurzen ist die 1 ich bin ich weiß
da bin ich keinen plan was genau das
ding hier thematisiert also klar ddr
aber in welche richtung es geht sie sind
süßigkeiten kennst du das alles ist ja
wirklich schon krass wenn da halt das
sind jetzt nur sachen drin die früher
die es früher in der ddr gab es war ja
auch so dass die ddr bürger manchmal
sachen die für alle anderen menschen
total normal waren wie bananen oder so
das kann nicht oder das haben die fast
nie gekriegt wo hat man gemerkt damals
vor osten oder westen hat eine banale
auf die mauer gelegt und aber abgewiesen
wurde
ach so jetzt muss ich ja eigentlich auch
mal kurz probieren sind mir die ddr
der sid aus sondern weil sie mit so
gesund aus der ddr orio nächstes bonbons
und ich glaube die sagen mir sogar das
recht mir nicht du weißt schon du
trinkst keinen kaffee im café dinger ja
was von roma also wenn ich hatten die
gleiche verpackung sehen aus wie
kastanien in klein und ich kann ja
schlecht sind die so ein bisschen hart
dann erkenne ich muss sagen ich finde es
schon geil also leisten wir bis jetzt
das ist die 3
hier ist etwas größer ist wenn alle
guten dinge drei tradition seit 1863 die
marke weber steht neben der herstellung
von der frischen wind blablabla aber
dann steht das leaks von ddr drauf das
sind wahrscheinlich sachen die man
heutzutage auch noch im supermarkt
kaufen kann ich mal von aus aber die
halt vielleicht ihren ursprung oder
diese dieses bekannt werden in der in
der ddr hatten eventuell keine ahnung
insel mit kisten sind aber ganz schön
hartnäckig gerade wie dies müsste
schmeckt nach wind und so ein bisschen
nach dem kissen also im in kissen
wir machen uns die firma nach außen hin
dass dadurch auch hier sind glaube ich
schon geregelt
das kenne ich ein kalter hund immer
hartmann kann ich echt nicht weil ich
mein spiel jetzt stelle ich den 80er
jahre kalender kannte man ja jedes
zweite produkt
deswegen waren wir zweiter und das
klingt auch mit ddr produkt und mein
gott ich habe gerade eine richtige
erleuchtung dann muss ich meiner oma
mitbringt ob ich das noch kennt das muss
ich das ding ist bei meiner oma gibt es
immer wenn irgendwie der geburtstags
oder so vor allem wir kinder früher was
richtig gefeiert das heißt kalte
schnauze das ist so kuchen die macht sie
halt selber und das sieht praktisch
genauso aus bonn musste her und so
schmeckt das auch das hier schmeckt zwar
jetzt nicht ganz so gut wie das von
meiner oma aber ich weiß was damit
gemeint ist und hat dann vermutlich den
ursprung in der ddr ist kalter hund
weißt du in der ddr kalter hund genannt
und im westen haben es kalte schnauze
leben irgendwie so also passt wirklich
neiße sachen wo kriegt man denn so etwas
jetzt heutzutage noch her
also macht weiter druck hat auch von
bieber da wird alles was jetzt von
bieber ist muss ich nicht mehr unbedingt
auch machen dass hier noch mal hier ein
bisschen durch wir wollen ja heute noch
fällig werden das nächste bieber classic
du bist dich jetzt nicht wo ich das
herkriegen soll also habe ich vorher
noch nie gesehen
aber irgendwann muss es ja geben so die
nummer 12
samen krokant also das ist zwar schon
wieder von biber sahne krokant das muss
ich jetzt mal probieren
das schmeckt ja sehr alt also weißt du
wo er wahrscheinlich so ein hipper
geschmack weist china war so in der ddr
vor dass hippe ding so ecken aus großes
neues von kieber bieber-fieber
mannschaft kann man aber erst inspektor
eigentlich gar nicht mehr stellt die
nächsten skin chocolat das hat also
anscheinend damals auch schon angefangen
das so begriffe verseucht wurden oder
das halt aus englischsprachigen raum ja
was übergeschwappt ist chocolat oder die
wurden da importiert aber das ging ja
ich bin jetzt auch kein ddr experte es
sind auf jeden fall jetzt wieder sagen
ja weil ich noch nie gesehen habe ach
die sind jetzt wieder ähnlich wie die
hier vermutlich sind die vom gleichen
hersteller von bonbons dann halt mal
drauf das sind so richtig alte um
höchstens zurück vielleicht irgendwann
mal in meiner oma mit bergen und so dann
habt ihr gleich auf die erste reihe
schon leer war hat man jetzt das sieht
so aus als würde das kenne ich nicht die
drohnen bonbon kennst du diese dinge
wenn man halt die sind so wenig aus und
dann hast du in dieses das war dann
irgendwie sohn dino oder muss oben den
kopf auf machen und dann waren da diese
teile drin und dann klappt es immer so
so sieht das auch das habe ich davor sei
notwendig da vorreiter
das ist ein film noch mal kurz darauf
macht schon mal hier die sieben aufbau
die nächsten top milch drops was wir
jetzt ein hipper name für die neuen
bonbons nennen wir sie doch mal
missbraucht und dann kam der nachfolger
raindrops milchproben tvi man schmeckt
als wäre nicht schlecht
jetzt kommt was großes michael krause
bonbons und metal lassen welche liebe
sofort hier komplett entschieden kannst
die ganze packung oder extra energie
aber es ist ja interessant dass also
anscheinend die sachen alle noch
hergestellt werden weil sowas
noch nirgendwo gesehen wo kann man das
denn einkaufen im ddr museum auch
gemacht dass sowie von google doch mal
schnell gegen land müsste man die ganze
backen reingeschossen wird er später
erfolgreich google market er hat gerade
bei 2000 euro eingekauft knapp 1000 und
wieso leute das fragt fragt nicht denen
nicht fragt nicht kennen sie das konzert
das video wird zu dass wir zu heftig
dass wir dieses andere heftig sagt der
jugend wie ist das jetzt papa
browser-krieg wird kann man auf jeden
fall bei amazon kaufen online online
sagt alte hund oder wieder so kalt kalt
darunter google ich mache jetzt kommt
ihm ein kalter hund eingibt kommt erst
mal direkt ein rezept dazu damit man
selber macht also hier kommt gar nichts
von irgendwelchen schokoriegeln doch
hier kalter hund wie früher
der klassiker von kalter hund von oma
hartmanns dresden onlineshop mich ja ja
hier stellt das kannst halt diese ganzen
sachen kann man online noch kaufen so
aber ein klarer kalter wind von oma hat
man gesehen so egal wir machen weiter an
die aussies von euch wer kennt das ja
was haben wir hier brause plus kommen
wir das ist halt so dass sieht halt so
alt aus ahoi brause das ist diese art
brause wahrscheinlich kam irgendwie ahoi
brause irgendwann hat die aufgekauft
oder vom markt gedrängt und dann hat
sich das ausgebaute plus erstmal schön
tippen schmeckt genauso wie er heute
muss ich sagen ich kaufe jetzt nur noch
brause plus wir haben wir das nächste
frau gar nicht langweilig das haben wir
schon das hat mir auch schon klh kann er
so was halt jetzt ich glaube jetzt jetzt
doppelt sich das so ein bisschen die 24
nicht aufgemacht haben als das zweite
peppermint bonbon guck mal das gab es
anscheinend auch schon in der ddr
und genau diese packung kann man
heutzutage auch noch kaufen im
supermarkt
doch knusperflocken konzept zeigt warum
[Applaus]
aber diese form diese bonbon form kenne
ich hier oder was die getroffen
so schön das merkt auch ganz gut hier
immer noch die 22 das nächste bombe
suite drop also von russian sind die
alle branchen ist auf jeden fall aber
wenn das so ein rot-weißer ist total ist
es also ich weiß was du meinst dann
haben wir jetzt noch so 24 er reist an
die hier oben habe ich noch was eine
schokolade so das kenne ich kann nicht
bei uns in meiner heimatstadt gibt es so
was noch so alt eingesessenen
schokoladen läden und bambina auch von
pat mcquaid ganz leicht wie mit ihm also
jetzt kommen wir zu 24 ja das kenne ich
du kennst du das ja ich dachte ich
dachte schon so hält das ist ja also
ohne scheiß das ist auch so was gibt es
auch bei jonas zuhause ich muss sagen
ich habe jetzt schon öfter nicht mehr
gesehen aber früher auch so wenn du
irgendwie so freunde von mir wenn da die
ober mit dem haus gewohnt hat dann gab's
immer so ne fahne und da lagen diese
dinge drin die gibt's dann auch in
größeren und ich habe sie so gerne
gegessen und letzten debatte dass ich zu
muss ich sagen die gar nicht mir
irgendwann ganzen leute und ich muss an
dieser stelle sagen das ist wirklich ein
kalender für die älteren unter euch und
kauft euch den mann bringen auch fürs
nächste jahr oder am besten noch für
dieses jahr also von einem kalender
liegt bis jetzt getestet auf jeden fall
der geist des hat mega spaß gemacht
danke dafür also danke für den kalender
und ich packe ich dir nie wie die
beschreibung leute aber hier den kanal
bald eine million auf ist aber meist
alex wie und wir sind unseren morgen 19
uhr gibt's neues video
haut rein